Speaker 1: Let's talk about this very
controversial golf tournament that took place
over the weekend at Donald Trump's Bedminster golf
club. This is part of the live golf tour alive.
This is controversial because it is backed by
Saudi Arabia, the Saudi royal family. Some of
the controversy relates to left handed golfer Phil
Mickelson, who has accepted a bunch of money to be
a sort of premier player on the live golf tour
and much controversy about. Listen, these are
human rights abusers. These are murderers. This is
an absolutely brutal regime. Should they really be
welcomed with open arms at American golf clubs?
Should Phil Mickelson be accepting money? Should
Trump be playing? Give me a break, guys. And
Donald Trump was confronted about this. This is
and by the way, tickets selling for as little as
a dollar. Very low levels of interest in attending
this thing. And it was mostly Trump tools. There
was a chant of four more years that broke out
at the event, a chant of Let's go, Brandon,
that broke out. All of this stuff. So very,
very thin crowds. Trump gets confronted about
listen these the Saudis like they did 911.
What about the criticism that this is an insult
to the families of the victims of 911? And
Trump's response is to go full conspiracy nut
and say no one's gotten to the bottom of 911.
What? Yes, we have. Check this out.
Speaker 3: You're so closely associated
with the city of New York. You, of all people,
understand the passion surrounding 911.
What do you say to those family members
who protested earlier this week and will
be doing so again on Friday? Well, nobody's
gotten to the bottom of 911, unfortunately,
and they should have. As to the maniacs
that did that horrible thing to our city,
to our country, to the world. So nobody's
really been there. But I can tell you that
there are a lot of really great people that
are out here today, and we're going to have
a lot of fun and we're going to celebrate and
moneys going to charity. A lot of money going
to charity. And really the best players in the
world, many of the best players in the world.
And soon you'll probably have all of them.
Speaker 1: So quite a word salad there.
And I would for any time. Any any any time.
Trump says that money is going to charity.
I would follow up to see if that's actually
the case. But what does it mean that we haven't
gotten to the bottom of 911? And interestingly,
before it became politically inconvenient for
Trump because he's just so enamored with the
Saudis. Trump used to say it was the Saudis
who did 911 period, like here is Donald
Trump in 2016 in an interview on Fox News.
He doesn't mince words at all. Q Right now, that.
Speaker 3: Front and center with so many people
I'm getting on the radio yesterday and today
is the 28 pages that were taken out of the 911
report. Saudi Arabia, evidently this reference to
Saudi Arabia, you have a Democratic senator, now,
retired Senator Graham, who says it's time for
the public to see him. Does Donald Trump believe
it's time for us to see these 28 pages? I do.
I think we should have seen it a long time ago.
You know, I think I know what it's
going to say. It's going to be very,
very profound having to do with Saudi Arabia and
Saudi Arabia's role on the World Trade Center and
the attack ads. That's very serious stuff. And,
you know, again, I've said it for a long time.
We attacked Iraq. And frankly, by attacking
Iraq, they were not the ones that knocked down
the World Trade Center. Right. And that for
a long time. Let's see what the papers say.
Speaker 1: That's absolutely right.
Trump didn't used to hesitate.
But here is what it's really about. This
is from the interview over the weekend.
Speaker 3: I've known these people for a long
time in Saudi Arabia and they've been friends
of mine for a long time. They've invested in many
American companies. They own big percentages of
many, many American companies. And frankly, what
they're doing for golf is so great. What they're
doing for the players is so great. The salaries
are going to go way up. The PGA was not loved
by a lot of the players, as you know, for a long.
Speaker 1: So there it is. That's what it's really
about. It's about business. That's fundamentally
what it is. Now, one more note on this. Our
friends, the good liars, Dave, Rahm and Jason,
they were at the live golf tournament and they
really did a good one with Phil Mickelson. This
has gone gig of viral millions and millions of
views as Phil Mickelson was getting
ready to hit his his golf ball. Our
friend Jason gave them some interesting words
of encouragement. Listen to this. All right.
Speaker 3: Last hour, Phil
Mickelson teed off here at the
16th hole just behind me. Here's what happened.
Speaker 1: Do it for the Saudi royal family.
Okay. So that that was very distracting to fill
the Phil Mickelson and he ended up having to
rethink that shot. So we've never gotten to
the bottom of 911. That's really the problem when
we talk about the Saudis, says Donald Trump now
very different tune to 2016 and very different
tune two points prior. So that's that.
And Trump going full conspiracy. If you're
curious about some of these clips and you're
only listening today, make sure to check out The
David Pakman Show Instagram at David Pakman Show